the changing table is ready and the
cupboard is packed with baby clothes
inna and mikhail are ready in just a few
days they're expecting their first baby
else as he has set his mobile on loud
and has already given inna his work
number just in case she isn't able to
reach him he says she'll be able to
contact his receptionist who can let him
know if things get going nothing unusual
there for expectant parents but these
two are planning on doing things a
little differently they've organized a
home birth fewer than 2% of babies in
Germany are born at home
inna and mikhail are among a growing
number of couples starting to buck this
trend nina has never spent more than an
hour or two in a hospital so finds the
idea of having to go to one to give
birth very strange
giving birth isn't a sickness she says
el says the couple have been questioned
about the possible risks involved in a
home birth people were never offensive
or suggested they were being
irresponsible he says but they were
advised to be cautious inna and mikhail
have two midwives who take it in turns
to be on call when inna goes into labor
it will be up to one of them to assist
with the birth that given her a list of
essential she'll need to help things run
smoothly
inna says she already has most of the
things on the list in the house like
hand towels and coffee but they've also
been asked to collect some extra
newspapers for her to lie on and some
plastic sheets to protect the band
an admin look this is an antenatal class
at the vessel clinic in Berlin the mums
and dads are given practice exercises to
help prepare them for childbirth most
expectant parents who attend this class
have already opted for a hospital birth
for most giving birth at home was never
an option
this father says that although it's
becoming fashionable he worries about
the risks of having a baby at home it's
not like your first-aid kit at home will
get you through it he says this dad asks
why anyone would willingly go back 400
years to a time when they didn't have
specialist emergency care
he says safety is more important than
doing things than natural way the
healthy women home births don't
statistically carry a much greater risk
but that doesn't mean to say that
midwife Stephanie Nowak would recommend
them to everyone there is some residual
risks she says although it's very small
it's there and this is something that
you just don't have at a clinic it's
this argument that has convinced Janine
and Marcus that having their baby at the
Virchow clinic is the right way to go we
want to maximize our chances of a safe
delivery Janine says they have the top
specialists here and it's one of the
best maternity wards in Germany these
antenatal classes are practically a must
for most expectant parents definitely no
guides these parents through the various
stages of childbirth for most it's a
daunting prospect Stephanie describes
how the baby makes its difficult journey
through the birth canal she tells the
mums when they need to push and when
various difficulties can arise
the baby's shoulders for example can
become stuck she shows how the baby will
rotate so it can pass through the pelvic
floor muscles then the rest is easy she
says it'll just pop out it's not all
hard work after the birth the baby is
cleaned up and placed on mums breast
giving both mom and baby a much-needed
break finding the right position to give
birth can't make labor a lot easier the
midwives recommend that mums are upright
so gravity can help with some of the
hard work Stephanie asks the expectant
parents to test out some of the options
they also practice massage techniques
just one way to ease the pain involved
in contractions it's often taken for
granted that dads will play an active
role during the birth but for Marcus and
Janine it's not back and white marker
says they've not decided whether he'll
be in the room when Janine gives birth
he says that if Shannon wants him there
he'll stay but he doesn't feel a
desperate need to be present and he
might not have - Janine says that when
things get difficult she might actually
prefer him to leave that way she can
concentrate on herself not have to worry
about what he's doing back at the cost
there are more exercises to learn and
though they might not ever have to put
any of this into practice the dads are
given no chance to ease up Stephanie
strictly forbids any cheating no hands
on knees allowed not for a full minute
these mums need to know how to pace
their breathing during contractions
fewer home births mean most expectant
parents don't know what to expect during
labor
there's a lot of fear of the unknown
stephanie says women who are afraid of
the pain often opt for a cesarean in the
hope that it will be more bearable
she says the labor itself is less
painful but the pain they experience
afterwards lasts a lot longer than a few
hours it takes to give birth every third
child in Germany is born by cesarean
section that's double the figure twenty
years ago the high caesarean rate is a
product of people's growing confidence
in hospital births but unless it's
medically necessary
Stephanie Nowak would still recommend
natural labor it's just so wonderful she
says all these basic instincts kick in
it's an unbelievable thing when a new
life comes into the world
she says that even after all her years
experience she still thinks it's a
miracle every time a miracle that Janine
and markers have to wait another six
weeks to experience for themselves but
for ena and Mikael it could happen at
anytime today they have an appointment
at a birthing center midwife catalina
newman has been looking after ena since
the start of her pregnancy
if ena and micahel decide against a home
birth at the last minute they would come
here Catalina goes through the options
with them she shows them the birthing
swing it allows you to be free to move
around and keeps you in an upright
position
but ena isn't enthusiastic and opts to
give it a Miss so close to the birth
Nina has checkups every few days
Catalina also shows the expectant dad
how he can check out how the baby's
doing
Marcus is a little hesitant he says he
still never sure what he's feeling this
hard bit here is the baby's bum he says
this is its back and this is its little
head and this is the amniotic fluid it's
much softer Katerina also checks to see
whether the baby's heartbeat is normal
this is something that could be done by
a doctor but inna and Mika else say they
feel more comfortable coming here she
believes doctors do everything too
quickly
she says they ask her how she's doing
and how her pregnancy is going but she
gets the feeling they don't have so much
time this could well be their last
appointment at the birthing center inna
says she feels like the baby could come
any day now and not before time she says
she's starting to find the pregnancy
extremely uncomfortable and she
struggles to find a comfortable position
to lie down that's not an uncommon
feeling for expectant mothers Katerina
says regardless of how easy the
pregnancy is at some point enough is
enough
five days later and just as planned
little Amaya was born into the world at
home the labor lasted 14 hours naturally
not disturbed by our cameras in a sense
she was relieved when the pain stopped
that's when she realized it was all over
and she was just so happy to see the
baby lying there Mikael it was
completely overwhelming all he could
manage to say was hello baby
he was so overcome he says he didn't
even register whether it was a boy or a
girl at first he says only when it
occurred to him to check did he realize
it was a little girl Catalina's
colleague was on call when ena went into
labor today she's visiting the young
family for the first time since the
birth midwives pay daily visits to
newborns on the first few days after the
birth she checks whether the baby's
belly button is recovering she also
looks to see whether it's putting on
enough weight this time it's good news
Amaya has put on weight is pleased Amaya
is less oh Nina and Mikael say they did
not regret their decision to have their
baby at home at any stage inna says she
can't wait for the moment when Amaya
asked where she was born and they can
say you entered this world in our home
in our bed